this video is sponsored by fabulous
early in my YouTube career I made fun of
a vehicle parties to try his luck in my
home country Hungary and was foolish
enough to write a post about it it was a
lot of fun and following the demise of
Andrew Tate the time is right to perform
another Deep dive into the online
menosphere but this time I don't just
want to laugh at them as easy as that
would be I also want to teach them how
to behave around women because they
obviously have no goddamn idea so put on
your cringe protection suit because
we're diving in
when referring to the online manosphere
we mean a collection of online spaces
where men give dating advice to other
men such advice can take many different
forms the importance of self-reliance
the benefits of adopting healthy habits
the damaging effects of Jewish
intellectualism and activism on Western
culture
that last article is from the website
called return of kings run by a guy
called Darius commonly known as Rush V
he wasn't the only contributor though he
had a whole roster of crazy people
writing the most bizarre evil and or
contradictory [ __ ] non-stop but then
Rouge Found Jesus in 2019 and more on
that later the reason I like Return Of
Kings is because of their honesty they
don't use euphemisms or try to hold back
on their actual beliefs they really put
it all out there women are sentient
livestock Joel Osteen is the Antichrist
feminism is a Jewish plot to stop you
from getting laid degeneracy in the US
will cause a Civil War the burden will
fall upon masculine men as it always
does in times of War people will revert
to the most basic survival Instinct the
soy boys will be busy hiding with the
women in their basements or agreeing
with whoever has the perceived power
before proceeding to murder rape and
loot those that disagree with them hang
on this soy boys will start to murder
rape and loot by your logic wouldn't
that make them gigantic primordial Giga
chants Return Of Kings is famous for
lots of things consistency not being one
of them one of their big themes on the
side is Western Progressive degeneracy
contrasted by Good Old Eastern Europe
during the traditional values and white
societies four additional European
countries to immigrate to if the West
collapses the West will fall because of
gay rights and white genocide France
won't let me publicly call Africans the
n-word if Trump doesn't win in 2016
here's where you can immigrate alright
as an Eastern European myself I'm
curious which countries he thinks are
better than the West
Serbia
[Laughter]
oh no I can already feel the mentally
illness just radiating from this post
but there is hope for these people all
they need to do is install another wrap
next to Tinder namely the app of today's
sponsor fabulous fabulous is your
digital coach a happiness trainer if you
will it's the number one self-care app
to help you build better habits and
achieve your goals fabulous really
helped me maintain my mental health as I
keep track of current events and helps
ward off the anxiety I get from looking
at examples of American urban planning
based on Behavioral Science it helps you
develop great healthy habits and
routines for a healthier more productive
and fulfilling Lifestyle the app will
help you create your own rituals these
small steps that lead to big changes the
two ways to use the app are habit
tracking and dedicated programs inhabit
tracking you can choose from 100 plus
recommended habits or you can create
your own fabulous that helps you build
these habits with gentle reminders and
content based on Behavioral Science
dedicated programs will help you achieve
your well-being goals over the course of
several weeks the new habits you pick up
can be added to your daily routine if
you so choose and God the illustrations
are nice it's one of my favorite things
about the app besides the fact that it's
methods actually work with the premium
version you can build and improve an
unlimited number of habits in your
routines and you have access to all
programs and exercises start building
your daily routine the first 500 people
to click the link below will get 25 of
their fabulous subscription thank you
for checking out fabulous ads like this
help support what I do and now back to
the program alright so Serbia according
to whoever wrote this [ __ ] level of
English medium difficulty of the local
language medium gun laws lenient well
this is a bit concerning quality of
women High the Polish girls of the
Balkans they like sex give importance to
their elegance and appearance but don't
send the ice queen vibe that ukrainians
and Russians can have oh someone is
insecure importance of religion medium
to high likelihood of a 50-year similar
cultural collapse low in view of recent
events their worst decision would be to
join the EU European and Global culture
has already brought a lot of damage wait
European culture is a problem now also
you have a problem with Western
degeneracy and people [ __ ] around so
you want to go to a more traditional
conservative country to [ __ ] around Mail
company Edition medium to high decent
Foreigner value as I said previously
serbs probably have one of the highest
level of game in Eastern Europe wow
that's a sentence I never thought I
would say written turbo folk culture and
recent bloody conflicts give them a bad
boy Head Start by treating women as
replaceable Commodities and War spoils
what you heard it here first folks Diego
stop Wars and the Bosnian genocide
turned sermon into real Giga Chads who
the [ __ ] wrote this [ __ ] Jean batav is a
martial artist from the Viking
stronghold of okay Czech Republic oh
[ __ ] here we go quality of women medium
to high love sex but less classy than
ukrainians or serbians exposed to a lot
of Gringo seeds since Brock turned into
a tourist hellhole but I'm sorry John
but up aren't you yourself a [ __ ]
Gringo by your own Logic No native
immigrant population medium avoid the
capital especially if you cannot stand
stack parties or pop crawls large number
of foreign students weak nationalist
sentiment oh yes all those westerners
going to the Czech Republic to have fun
and [ __ ] women am I right Jean batav if
you were just a bit less self-aware you
would cease to be sentient male
competition low checks are immaturity
Low T and beta girls love Gringos but
you will not be there first no wonder it
is a swingers gave it a [ __ ] hotspot
what likelihood of a 50-year similar
cultural collapse possible the
xenophilic nature of the Czechs and
their Placid character could be their
downfall the xenophilic nature of the
checks the xenophilic nature of the
Czechs one of the most racist [ __ ]
countries in the whole EU where only 40
of the population would be comfortable
with a person of a different ethnicity
being the leader of the country I'm
starting to notice a pattern here in my
older video when Dollar Store Kingpin
described Hungary as a Hungarian I
immediately knew he didn't really
Venture Beyond inner city Budapest and
that's the same Vibe I'm getting from
this guy after having lived in Prague
for three years it's almost like these
guys just wander around the tourist trap
areas all day angrily going through
Tinder no wonder they're angry all
that's left for normal men are rotten
women apparently Nature has given
Humanity a roughly one to one ratio of
adult men to women but the most
attractive women are being taken out of
circulation to either join alpha male
harems or participating degenerate
lifestyle choices this leaves the
average man particularly no choice in
settling down with a mentally stable and
cute woman in her prime and then here's
a magazine cover of a successful
restaurant owner lady with dyed hair and
Tattoos okay
four wives which is what my wealthy
Iranian grandfather did on his way
Desiring 24 or so children that included
my dad the exact number is a mystery he
took only three women that an Iranian
men of lessons could have married
creating a societal imbalance but that's
nothing compared to what we have in the
modern Western world where a single
famous man can command the sexual
attentions of dozens if the thousands of
women in their sexual crime spoiling
these women for normal men who don't
have the ability to tingle their vagina
what the [ __ ] is he on about okay so let
me understand this the Western world is
falling because men are becoming
feminine soy boy beta Cox but it's also
falling due to an epidemic of Titanic
Giga chats subverting Society with their
overwhelming masculinity well which is
it then if Western Civilization is based
on masculine values wouldn't these
atlassian Giga chats be the ones holding
it up with their genitals presumably if
you think this makes no sense you're
right it doesn't also how can a single
famous men spoil thousands of women in
their Prime Rouge just because a man is
famous and lots of women lost after him
or something that doesn't mean those
women are off the section your
Marketplace you can find famous people
hot and date others at the same time
unless your real problem is your
insecurity that they might find someone
else attractive beside you at any rate
as you can see the manosphere is an
inconsistent incoherent convoluted
self-contradicting train wreck inundated
by far-right ideologies has it ever
occurred to these [ __ ] that
acting like a bonobo ape might be the
reason why they keep encountering those
rotten women if you want to settle down
with a mentally stable and cute woman in
her prime maybe you should start acting
like a mentally stable guy in his prime
and maybe stop comparing them into dogs
the article features Instagram pictures
of girls who look like your average gold
diggers as example of rotten women
personally I never had to worry about
gold diggers a because I'm not a middle
eastern millionaire and B I don't
constantly posture as wealthy and
Powerful all these [ __ ] keep posing
with expensive cores wads of cash
private planes and the like and then
wonder why they can't check the
quote-unquote rotten women what sort of
women would those pictures attract the
cute Eastern European tread wife wanting
to settle down or the gold digger
looking to get in on your wealth if
you're out there on the dating field and
the wrong people keep coming after you
the common denominator is you of course
the basic idea behind the pickup artist
[ __ ] aesthetic is that supposedly
girls like [ __ ] and reject nice guys
and it's all based on one big
misunderstanding from high school which
I will now explain and clear up as
promised women like the [ __ ] and
reject the nice guy is melosphere 101
the Alpha and Omega of every pickup
artist make Tao red pillar and so on and
it's based on a complete
misinterpretation men usually experience
the nice guy [ __ ] dynamic in high
school when the hormones start kicking
in and sexuality is suddenly on the
table but in those teenage years
everyone is still figuring stuff out and
have zero experience in dating or
relationships at that point the [ __ ]
are far more successful with girls than
the nice guys it's the Virgin vs chat
meme but in real life the [ __ ] is
cold emotionally distant talks down to
girls ignores their messages ghosts them
and so on the nice guy is always there
acts like the emotional tampon puts
girls on a pedestal immediately responds
to messages keeps following them
everywhere Etc so why do high school
girls like the [ __ ] and ignore the
nice guy
because the nice guy is [ __ ] boring
this is it this is why girls prefer the
[ __ ] over the nice guy also
inexperienced high schoolers tend to
misinterpret being an [ __ ] as
strength and confidence most women
aren't after some walking parody of
masculinity they like confident guys who
aren't boring being an [ __ ] has
nothing to do with it in fact Beyond
High School being an [ __ ] is actually
a detriment after all nobody likes being
around [ __ ] but don't take it from
me take it straight from the horse's
mouth let's read together from the
introduction of rushri's book Bang
it started in the spring of 2001. I was
21 years old and spent my free time on
the computer reading message boards or
playing games I had no skill with women
and the ones I knew either used me for
my brain to tutor them or as an
emotional tampon to feel better about
guys who didn't take their [ __ ] I
remember thinking how stupid the other
guys were to treat such pretty and nice
girls so poorly didn't they realize
those girls will eventually get angry
and stop talking to them after a couple
of weeks of hesitation I finally asked
her out on a casual date to the movies
she said she couldn't because she was
very busy weeks later I saw her around
campus holding hands with another guy
instead of listening to lame love songs
like I usually did for the first time I
got angry a lifetime of frustration and
not getting what I wanted became focused
on that one girl I was bitter that I a
nice guy was getting past the word for
guys I thought were losers so I started
to ignore her if I did end up talking to
her I would cut our conversations short
when she asked me to study I would lie
and say I was studying alone only to
have her stumble upon my study group
late at night in the library I started
feeling good for treating her poorly I
hated her and everything she stood for
which was my failure with women
but then something interesting happened
she started making a strong effort to
gain my attention and favor it was as if
the order I pulled away the closer she
would come to me that was the first time
I understood that changing my behavior
could affect how girls reacted to me
soon it became clear that interacting
with women wasn't very different from
the games I played with my nice guy
friends where changing tactics and
strategies yielded different results
right so allow me to explain this whole
women think to You Pick Up Artist types
because you obviously have no idea the
secret to dating isn't being an [ __ ]
to women it's about being a good guy
with an edge you are there for someone
but they ask for help within reason
you're empathetic but not let people use
you as an emotional tampon you don't put
people on pedestals or look down on them
you treat them like equals you respond
to messages a bit later because you have
stuff to do but you never ghost people
online or offline you are confident
polite nice but not too nice as in a
doormat you don't wear your emotions on
your sleeves so the other person gets to
wonder a bit if you like them or how
much you like them this is exciting and
it makes you not boring therefore
attractive to many notice how Rouge by
being an [ __ ] accidentally emulated
many of these characteristics he stopped
dogging her with his affection he made
himself scarce he stopped acting like a
desperate Orbiter but the problem is
being an [ __ ] is becoming less and
less attractive as the years go by
acting like some thread Pro dumb [ __ ] as
a 40 year old man might appeal to
teenage girls or the quote unquote
Russian women but anyone above the age
of 25 especially the those wanted Q
thread wives will increasingly find you
pathetic as people like Rouge keep doing
this embarrassing manly man bit into
their 30s and 40s it becomes harder and
harder to find people romantically
interested in them they think it's
western degeneracy or feminism or the
Jews running women or something but the
truth is they just repel an insane adult
self-respecting woman by acting like
high school [ __ ] Rush V in
particular had a very tough time with
this as the years went by and he was
approaching 40 I imagine he got more and
more lonely his toxic attitude and
chauvinistic foreign views repelled
every woman from around him in that
moment of hopelessness and vulnerability
as he stood there Lonely with this
emptiness inside staring defeating the
face on all fronts in 2019
found God
of course he's still basically a Nazi
and now a proud member of the Russian
Orthodox Church go over here nowadays he
spends his time doing multiple our
streams on Odyssey the bombastic Fred
bro is gone all we see now is he
defeated broken man he basically had the
life journey of the High Sparrow from
The Song of Ice and Fire consequently
Return Of Kings has been on Hiatus since
2019 and good [ __ ] riddance Jesus
Christ I guess what I want you to take
away from this video is first pickup
Artistry is [ __ ] second don't treat
women as livestock and third being an
[ __ ] isn't attractive being confident
polite and somewhat challenging is add a
bit of humor and you're sad at the end
of the day be the person you'd want your
children to bring home as their partners
[Music]
thank you